ismail yosgot says he'll never celebrate
his birthday again
it was one day before his birthday in
april 2006 that his 21 year old son
haleed was murdered shot as he worked in
the family's internet cafe in the city
of castle
he was the ninth victim in a series of
racially motivated killings
mr yosgot gave evidence of the trial of
biata chapa who is accused of
involvement in the murders he said he
found his son in a pool of blood at the
internet cafe
for years the authorities wrongly
suspected the family and didn't
investigate a possible right-wing link
to the crime
scene one of the goals of this case is
to make clear the family was unfairly
suspected
they were spied on by an investigator
their telephone was tapped
even though mr yoskat told police the
only motive could be racism that the
family had nothing to do with it and
that the investigations were heading in
the wrong direction
one witness andreas t testified that he
had been in the internet cafe but that
he didn't see the murder and only read
about it later in the newspaper
andreas t attracted attention because he
worked for germany's domestic
intelligence agency at the time he said
his failure to come forward as a witness
was a mistake
he also expressed his sympathy to the
families of all the victims